. So this next story, this this segment I'm
going to do right now, this is the prototypical
segment that I think is some of the best stuff
that we do.
And it does terribly in terms of audience.
But it is so interesting and it is so worth
doing and so informative.
Let's dig right into it.
I told you previously that Joe Biden will
be selecting Janet Yellen as his treasury
secretary.
And we talked about Janet Yellen s politics.
And I pointed out there are things that should
make progressives reasonably happy about the
selection of Janet Yellen.
There are things that might make progressives
not so happy about Janet Yellen.
But the big picture about Janet Yellen as
treasury secretary is that anything that Joe
Biden is able to get done with the House and
Senate that he ends up having, Janet Yellen
is not likely to stand in the way at all,
meaning that she will not be the impediment
to Joe Biden getting his campaign platform
done.
She's a relatively good selection.
She's the first woman in that position.
And she's a true economic.
She's she's an academic.
She's an academic from the field of economics.
She is also beyond that, a really clever economist.
And I was doing some research on her and came
across an article that she published along
with George Akerlof in the quarterly Journal
of Economics back in May of 1990.
This is 30 years ago now.
OK, and she published a paper about the so-called
fair wage effort hypothesis.
This is not just economics, it's social psychology
and it's sociology and it's brilliant and
fascinating.
And it just reinforces that Joe Biden is picking
serious people.
Donald Trump's treasury secretary is Stephen
Manoogian, who was a hedge fund guy who lived
in a hotel and drove a Porsche while he was
getting his undergraduate degree and then
went and worked, you know, in big finance,
hedge funds, et cetera.
Janet Yellen is a Ph.D. in economics and has
published scholarly articles and developed
original ideas of her own and the idea that
she has developed in this fair wage effort
hypothesis.
This is, again, 30 years old, but it's talking
about the rigor, academic rigor that Janet
Yellen is capable of.
The idea is the following.
If your wage that you are paid falls short
of your perception of what would be a fair
wage for that job, you start to not work as
hard and you're less productive.
The idea of hiring someone else wouldn't work
unless you can find someone who really doesn't
understand how their wage relates to what
would be a fair wage for the job you've hired
them for.
And we've actually observed this phenomenon.
You will you often will end up seeing people
with different skill levels doing the same
job and getting paid the same amount and they
end up with almost identical productivity
would be strange intuitively.
Right?
I mean, you've got two people doing the same
work.
One is significantly more skilled in ways
that are relevant to that work.
But because of this pressure that Janet Yellen
describes that exists where you are comparing
your wage to the fair wage, even if you are
more skilled and you would be able to be significantly
more productive, you will produce down to
the level you believe is appropriate for the
wage you are being paid.
Very, very interesting.
There are lots of studies in terms of people
having a perception of the fairness of the
wage they're being paid.
One such study is Lawler and O'Gara, which
you can Google if you're interested in this.
And they did some really simple but well controlled
experiments where they would pay a set amount
per task.
And when they paid less for the same task,
given equally qualified and skilled individuals,
when you paid less, productivity went down.
Now, if you're interested in this, we're linking
actually to Janet Yellen article in the description
for the YouTube video on this story.
But it's really quite elegant because it directly
refutes a lot of really bad right wing talking
points about the minimum wage and wages in
general.
And I'll give you some examples of this.
There's this talking point from the right
where it's sort of like a reductio ad absurdum
where they say, listen, if we want people
to have more money and paying them more is
better, why stop at a 15 dollar minimum wage?
Why not make it one hundred and fifty dollars
an hour or a thousand dollars an hour?
Just pay people, make everybody multimillionaires.
Now, intuitively, intuitively, we know that
that's idiotic.
And one of the reasons it doesn't make sense
is that paying people one hundred and fifty
dollars or a thousand dollars instead of just
a reasonable minimum wage, it would not be
an equilibrium wage that makes any sense in
terms of the cost of living nor relative to
other professions.
It doesn't make any sense.
But what Janet Yellen hypothesis adds here
is that paying somebody saying, well, let's
set the minimum wage to 150 or a thousand,
it wouldn't be in line with a fair wage.
If you survey people about what would be a
fair wage for traditional minimum wage work,
it's not going to be one hundred and fifty
dollars or a thousand dollars an hour.
It'll be much closer to the fifteen dollars
an hour.
That's widely now being discussed.
I'll give you another right wing talking point
that is implicitly debunked by Janet Yellen
hypothesis.
If you increase the minimum wage, you force
businesses to lay off employees and it increases
unemployment.
Well, hold on a second.
If Janet Yellen is right and the literature
suggests she is, if you pay people less, you're
making them less productive, which means you
either need to pay them to work longer hours
or you need to hire more of them to get to
the same level of productivity that costs
you more as the employer as well.
The other one, you.
Here, which is similar, is you raise the minimum
wage, you raise the price of consumer goods,
well, the same analysis applies if you lower
the wage and you make employees less productive
as a result, you still need more employees
or you need employees working more hours to
produce your stuff, you'd theoretically still
need to raise the price of the goods that
you are selling.
So it's quite elegant, very interesting stuff.
And again, read it.
It's only about eight, 10 pages.
If you don't include all of the charts and
data at the end, you could read it in 10,
15 minutes.
But you will very quickly realize that we
are going in the direction of having actual
expert adults in positions of power upcoming.
And we will have our political disagreements
with them.
But we should all be welcoming this after
the fiasco charade that the Trump administration
has been.
Check out the article.
Let me know your thoughts.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
this.